have you forgotten what happened to our
grandfather the Mad King invited him to
King's Landing and roasted him alive
hey everybody is Charlie there are a lot
of people that were asking about this
new John Sansa scene and I waited a
little while to wait for people to
actually verify that it was a new scene
and not just reuse footage from season
seven but it is him with a longer beard
coming back to Winterfell with Daenerys
her dragons and all the people that were
part of their alliance so the fact that
Sansa has this look on her face tells
you a lot about what the beginning of
the season is gonna be like so if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the Game of Thrones
videos there's giveaway stuff that I'll
explain at the end of the video but the
big thing first is is that she's
actually looking at Daenerys her dragons
in like say Lord Varys and everybody
else like Tyrion that she remembers from
her time at King's Landing so yeah she's
really happy to see the person she
thinks is her brother come back but
she's not totally happy about this
alliance in all these people from King's
Landing like Tyrion and Varys in
particular are bringing up all those
memories of when she was abused by
Joffrey for so long so keep in mind this
is probably one of the early if not the
first scene from the first episode I
don't think this is gonna open the
season with this but then Blake cresting
over the hill on Winterfell that would
be a really badass way to open the
season but remember the way they open
season seven you had the Arya revenge
scene just a big callback all the way to
the red wedding then they cut directly
to brans vision of the night Kings army
so they might actually choose just to
remind people about the ticking clock
this season to open on a scene like the
pilot where you open on White Walkers
and the night King instead of opening on
all the heroes like just to remind you
that everybody is about to die this
season unless they do something about it
regardless of what they did I think it
just makes a little more sense to remind
you where the thread is then show you
scenes like this so that you know that
the drama has to pass because that's all
this scene is setting up just a little
bit of that early drama like we saw at
the beginning of season 7 between Jon
and Sansa so in the way that they
brushed past that within the first two
episodes because season eight only has
six episodes I think they're gonna blow
past that even more quickly but there's
a couple big things that they're setting
up here this is happening right after he
walks in - it's not like they've been
there for a while like he walks through
the gates there's a bunch of other
northerners behind Sansa to greet them
so he hasn't explained sex boat like
they haven't had their first
introduction like she obviously knows
who Daenerys is because she sees the
dragons but then John is gonna have to
turn around to say this is Queen
Daenerys and this is obviously before
brand has time to spoil the mood by
blurting out that John is a Targaryen
and then you can kind of guess what the
domino effect is going to be hopefully
that happens either in a moment where
John and Daenerys are standing together
with some family members and friends or
when all the Lords of the north are in
the Great Hall talking about something
completely different and they just
immediately shuts them up by saying John
as a Targaryen sophie turner
exaggerating a little said that everyone
would be betraying everyone else during
season eight now she was just hyping it
up a little bit but I think that's where
we get into moments like this where
people look at these shots of John and
Sansa embracing then they see the John
Daenerys scenes that they put in the
promo from season seven and they're
obviously trying to pit the John Sansa
against the John Daenerys and even
though I know there's a lot of crazy
shipping that goes on the internet what
I think you know most likely scenario is
is that the Lords of the north once they
find out that John is the true heir to
the throne they'll have the knee-jerk
reaction of wanting to back his claim
because they still hate Targaryen
regardless of what they need to tears
for to defeat the night king they'll
want to find any way they can to avoid
putting Daenerys in power that means
that they would have to back John's
claim with someone else to marry him to
so that's I think why people are
thinking that they might want John to
marry Sansa
even though remember only six episodes I
don't think there's a whole lot of time
for that kind of drama logically you
just have to assume what John's reaction
is going to be when he finds out that
he's related to Daenerys he'll have
enough problems with that there's the
foreshadowing that Daenerys is going to
be pregnant which is probably going to
get rid of some of the drama and create
whole new problems because John in the
books has a big problem with bastards he
grew up one he doesn't want to have any
hand in creating anymore bastards
himself that would require that he gets
married to Daenerys get married to his
aunt so after having problems knowing
that he's related to her it's gonna be
even harder to come around on marrying
her I don't think he would set that
forbidden quote-unquote relationship
aside for another forbidden relationship
and even though he wasn't really close
to Sansa he shares just as much DNA with
her
his cousin as he does with his aunt
Daenerys so it'll be just trading one
forbidden relationship for another and
that just doesn't sound like something
that John would be down for like that
would be the moment in the argument if
he's having one with the Lords of the
north where he starts banging Longclaw
on the ground to get them to shut up
that doesn't even get into the idea of
people dying remember they're killing
off most of the main cast during season
eight they'll just start peeling off
starting at least around Episode three
because that's probably when the first
big battle but the night king is going
to happen so based on the way they
plotted out it looks like this is
happening relatively early episode one
then either by the end of the first
episode or by the beginning of the
second episode Jamie and all the other
smaller reunion scenes happen like oh
I'm the guy that pushed you out of the
window cannot wait for that brand
reunion then they have time to all get
on the same page you know with whatever
background drama they have because of
Jon's heritage as a Targaryen before the
night King attacks but let me know in
the comments do you actually think that
they're gonna save the brand Targaryen
reveal for later in the season before
the second big battle that they have
down at King's Landing with Cersei and
anybody that's left alive because it
kind of seems like Winterfell is gonna
be destroyed so it just sounds like they
want them to have this first big battle
there's just so much family drama that's
going on outside of what's happening
with the night king that they might just
choose to spread that out a little bit
instead of dropping it all in the first
episode the downside of this is that it
doesn't really tell you everybody that's
in that party with Jon and Daenerys like
is Gendry there is there going to be
reunion with Arya because Arya is still
definitely a Winterfell at this point
and I know a lot of people are wondering
about where's ghost
where's Nymeria there was a scene that
they filmed with Jon and ghost him just
saying goodbye before he went to see
Daenerys during season seven so I think
they just cut that for time so that
means that he's still alive ghost is
still just waiting there for John to
come back so I think given that they
want to pay everything off and close all
these arcs they wouldn't leave ghosts to
rot out in the wilderness of deleted
scenes now as for how much ghosts would
be used in big battle scenes I don't
know how much they dedicated to CG for
stuff like that I think it's actually
harder for them from a special-effects
standpoint to film scenes like this
where they're up really close next to
them like you look at the way they shot
this Arya Nymeria scene and they're not
in the same frame together
for very long like they crosscut it a
little bit so you just can't quite tell
and it doesn't quite look as good as the
scenes that they have with the Dragons
if you wonder why we haven't seen them a
lot in the last couple of seasons it's
one to save money on CGI so that they
could do more with the Dragons but to
because they've never quite been able to
perfect the scenes where they're
actually standing there next to each
other in frames so they just avoided it
altogether so hopefully now that John
has had that first meeting with drogon
we get to see what ghost thinks of the
Dragons when he meets them but because
he has that special mental link with
John he takes a lot of emotional cues
from him remember that all the stark
children are low level wargs is just
that bran is the only one that can
actively use it right now the other ones
have a genetic predisposition that
allows them to do that but that's why
all the Starks have wolf dreams in the
books just because they're doing it
unconsciously it's a muscle like
anything else you don't exercise it you
won't be able to do it consciously so in
the way that I don't think they're gonna
do a whole lot with this John Sansa John
Daenerys drama plot I don't think that
they're gonna get into any other Starks
besides Brand worgen during season eight
but the only ones as of book five that
still have wolf dreams are the ones that
have dire wolves that are still alive so
it's almost like you know the ability
has never been stretched so it's not
only gonna start doing it all of a
sudden but like I said on my trailer
video yesterday they'll be peppering new
footage out for the rest of the year
like that so whatever ends up dropping
any new step I will totally do videos
for it but there is a new round of that
4k blu-ray giveaway all you have to do
to enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video congratulations to
the winner from that last big video
Chelsey Peterson please email me on the
back end of my channel so I can get your
contact details click here to rewatch
that new promo and click here to learn
all about what's going on with the
prequel series thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
you